thank you all for coming in the last 48
hours I've had to focus on being a
racehorse trainer but actually I have
very little to add to what we've both
said over two years ago when we were
check out everything absolutely
everything we said two years ago and
proved to be true rebecca has been
through an unprecedented investigation
of an incredibly forensic and personal
nature the likes of which we probably
never seen and I would just like to say
how proud I am Rebecca and of the
dignity ish in your show I Charlie said
we have a lot much divided the reason
that we said two years I mean of course
the last few years have been tough for
both of us and for those closest to our
but more importantly they've been tough
for everybody on all sides there have
been affected by the issues highlighted
by this case and therefore throughout
the three-year leave investigation and
through our eight month trial at the Old
Bailey we've always tried to keep our
troubles in perspective I mean after all
you know we we have a happy and healthy
daughter we have our brave and resolute
mums that been at court most of the time
and we've had strong and unwavering
support from all our friends our family
and for more legal team because we
believe the mug from the beginning
I am innocent
that I was charged with and I feel
vindicated by the unanimous verdict
what's your reaction when he was drugged
Nicholson tonight when I was arrested is
it was in the middle of a maelstrom of
controversy of politics and of comments
some of that was fair that much livers
not so I'm grateful for the jewelry very
good jewelry for coming to their
decision what's your reaction to the
extent of criminality that has been
exposed at the two papers you worked at
mrs. i think i'd like to say it's been a
time of reflection for me I've learned
some valuable lessons and hopefully and
the wise for it do you wish you are done
more to expose the criminality mrs.
Brooks do you wish you had done more to
expose the criminality I think that said
I'm incredibly proud at the many
journalists I've worked with throughout
my career and the great campaigns that
we have fought and won would you wish
you'd um Melissa's chief executive do
you wish you had done more to expose the
criminality all I couldn't say to you
all is that today my thoughts are with
my former colleagues and their families
who faced future trials I'm going to do
everything I can to
then as I know how anxious the times
ahead are making us your message to
vehicle can i ask you whether you've
spoken at all sadly corso Rebecca which
I just like okay what I'm going to do
now I hope you don't mind is I can't say
too much today I have to be careful for
my former colleagues saying what I say
my daughter is there like I said in
their families but now we're going home
early cuz motion how do you feel about
what Randy